Hello everyone. Thank you for
having me here. So before I start,
just curious, how many of you are working
on AI stuff? Okay, raise your hand.
Oh,
a lot.
So today my topic is AI startup
ecosystem in the US and China.
I will provide some comparative
perspectives on the two ecosystems.
Okay. So many of you have noticed
that AI startups grow rapidly.
Okay.
So if you look at Ai Unicorns,
Unicorns,
meaning startups have over 1
billion valuations, there are 20,
32 Ai Unicorns in by 2018.
So this is a report here by CB insights.
This is about 10% of the whole Unicorn
club and that this percentage is
continued growing.
Now that there's 17 companies from us,
10 from China.
So it looks like us has
more AI unit concern China.
But if we look at this figure,
um,
we look at top five
most funded Ai Unicorns.
Actually China has rate and the most
too well founded Ai Unicorns are from
China. Maybe you are not familiar
with some of the companies.
I will provide you a little
bit quick background.
Okay.
The first well funded company
is caught by dams. Actually.
They have a big office in Culver
city by dance raised three billing.
It's a Chinese company. It has a number
of products, but the two main products,
one is total,
which is AI powered new zap.
It has over 500 million
monthly active users.
The second one, which is probably
more popular called Tick Tock,
they have over 500 million
monthly active users globally.
This is a AI powered,
a short video sharing app.
If you haven't use it,
please have a try.
Okay.
Now the second well funded Ai
Company is called a sense time.
The company raised 2.6 billion
in folks on computer vision.
Now since time has over 700 enterprise
customers and the strategic partners
globally,
it has applications over
more than 10 industries.
The main technology or product and
have since time is facial recognition.
There's facial recognition. Service
is serving over 400 million people.
Yeah,
so the fifth well found,
the company is called a ubi tech.
It's another Chinese company.
This company is building
their service robotics, right?
This looks human like robotics
are produced by UV tech.
There's a lot of robotics,
so the revenue in 2018 is
actually over 300 million.
So the Saudis robots very well and their
sales increased over 500 times within
four years.
Okay.
If we look at the two other companies
from the U s they are auto autonomous
driving companies,
neuro and Argo Ai,
they both raised a billing
euro is a little bit different.
They are building this self
driving car for food delivery.
Well it can also deliver
other stuff later on.
Argo AI is more like standard
self driving car company.
They build in self driving cars.
We notice that these five top,
most well funded AI companies,
they are all funded within a few years
and there are so many other unicorns they
grow so rapidly.
So the question I want to ask is why are
these AI startups growing so rapidly?
There are a couple of reasons.
First,
there's continuous progress
in data processing,
computing power and the algorithms.
If we look at this two fingers,
this is some statistics
on image net dataset.
I think many of you should know that.
Um,
if we look at as the classification
accuracy, image net Dataset,
the accuracy continuous to
improve, right? In 2014, um,
and actually after 2014 it beats humans
and now it continuous to improve.
Another very interesting observation
is that in the past a year or two,
the training time and the image net to
building this machine learning models
actually jobs dramatically right,
sounds to all these parallel
computing cloud computing.
Now the second reason for the rapid
growth of AI companies is a significant
growth of venture capital into Ai.
So this figure shows the global
AI investments year by year.
We can see that the trend is that VC
money is growing year by year into Ai.
And in 2008,
the VC money total actually
is 70% up compared to 2017.
Now this curve actually
shows the number of deals.
So interestingly,
in 2018,
the number of deals that raised money
is actually a fewer than that in 2017
and we are observed a large
loans but fewer teachers,
fewer deals, meaning fewer
companies. Actually raised money.
So why is that?
Why given that so much money is into
AI but money are concentrated on deals,
larger, um, is fewer deals.
There are a couple of reasons but the
main point is that in some AI fields,
the bigger guest speaker,
basically big companies,
big startups are easier to
attract them more money.
So there are a couple of reasons.
So one is the data network effect because
these Ai Unicorns tended to collect
more and more data and these data actually
provide a company more advances in
technology.
Secondary,
these Ai Unicorns are easier to
attract a more AI talents and you know,
more I'd talents means right,
you have more power in terms
of technology development.
Suddenly these Ai Unicorns are
easier to expand to more territories.
Tick talk, as I said, the
core product of by dense,
they are actually expanded to the US,
Asia and Europe.
Now they have over 500 million
monthly active users globally.
The first reason is that these bigger AI
startups can expand to more industries
easier.
Since time as an example,
they already covers over 10 industries.
No. A natural question to ask is,
well, there'll be more capital into AI,
probably. Yes. If you
look at the US VC market,
2018 is actually a record breaking year.
So this shows the total venture capital
money raised by US startups in 2018.
Right?
The amount is significantly larger
than 2017 and the years before.
Okay.
So it looks like this is great timing
for us AI startups because there's a lot
of money in the market.
What about China in
southern 17 2017 actually,
the, the AI funding, the VC
money in China exceeds the u s
right.
The total fund in China is about 48%
of the total AI funding globally.
Well, you as has only 78, sorry, 38
but things are getting changing.
Uh, so if you look at this figure,
right,
starting from 2018 so the number of deals
and also the amount of venture capital
money in China is decreasing.
So in China,
startups and the VC's are
facing so called Capitol winter.
Why is that? Uh, there's multiple reasons.
One reason is the
slowing economy of China.
And secondary also because of the
flooring share price of the tech giants,
people are afraid of the market. Uh,
there could be some other reasons,
but the main point is that in China,
the VC market, it's different.
It's getting changing. And this may
challenge the Chinese are Unicorns.
This other reason for the raptor growth
of Ai Unicorns is the thriving industry
applications nowadays you can see AI,
unicorns are solving big problems in
almost each industry. You can imagine,
uh,
I will go to these details later,
but these massive application drives
the rapid growth of Ai Unicorns.
No.
Let's ask a second important question.
Why do some AI companies grow so rapidly
in one country but not in the other?
We notice like companies like
by dance like sense time,
they are big in China but not in the
u s right in the u s this autonomous
driving startups raised a lot
of money but now seem in China.
So why is that?
So to answer this question,
actually we have four key observations.
So first for I and D
USA is a head of China
second that it for manufacturing.
China has its own advantages.
So delay for B,
two B industries us is stronger.
So what is B two B B Two B
stands for business to business.
Meaning the customers are enterprises.
Well for B two C and B
Two g China is stronger.
B Two c stands for business to
consumer or the customers or consumers.
B Two g g stands for government.
Many you are serving government hell for
B two C and B Two g China is stronger.
The force of the observation is that
Chinese unicorns actually I adopting some
unique growth strategies.
So I will come to this
observations one by one.
First R and D USA is a
huddle ahead of China. Now,
if we look at Ai Talents,
right?
So if we look at that,
the talents in or AI companies,
u s as about 1.5 x of the talent,
the number of talents in China, uh, the
difference is not significant, right?
But if we look at the
number of top AI talent,
u s has much more advantage that the
top AI talent in the u s is 5.3 times of
the number in China, right? All
these AI talents are very important.
The for int for developing
this disruptive technologies.
Another example is two, looking at
the autonomous driving technology.
This is sort of integrated AI technology
because you are building a complex
system. This is a figure is
very interesting. It's report,
it's published by DMV in 2018.
It shows a miles per this engagement.
What does it mean?
It means how many miles can have a self
driving car drive until a human gets
involved. So we can see that. Uh,
the first one is Waymo develop a
by Google. Waymo is obvious today,
the top one in terms of the test,
right? But this is in Tucson,
the 18. Uh, for now,
Google is absolute leader.
Uh,
in this chart you s has 16 companies.
China has four,
looks like us self driving cost companies
are much more than China and other
countries. Neuro Aurora,
I also doing well, right?
You notice that the top five
companies are from the U s we need,
they are ahead of China.
Uh,
interestingly in euro and Arora
I founded by x school goes.
So Waymo is a leader in
self driving car technology.
It has built a large pool of talents way
more actually develop the technology 10
years ago. Right? So, uh,
and the larger pool of talent developer
by Waymo actually helped other self
driving costs to boot Dell technologies.
So,
so Google made a big impact in this space.
No.
The second observation is
that manufacturing in China
has its unique advantages.
Why is that?
Um,
because there's relatively low cost of
Labor's and not raw materials. In China,
manufacturing infrastructure,
uh, mature, uh, highways,
roads and paths in China
are well developed.
So the litters detailed division of tasks.
So the pipeline of manufacturing,
it's very mature. Examples of the, uh,
examples are UV tech,
robotics.
They can produce this kind of robotics
in fairly cheaper price than anywhere
else.
Show me is another great example.
Show me beauty ecosystem of smart
devices in relatively cheaper price.
So the takeaway for the u s startups
is that you can leverage this
manufacturing advantages in China.
Uh, good examples are lime and birth,
right? They are building this scooters,
which you can see a lot in Santa Monica.
Uh,
actually these scooters are mainly
developed in China and these companies can
cover the cost just whizzing 20 days.
Touring is one example.
The company we invested
doing security robots,
it can patrol indoors and outdoors
because the hardware are manufactured in
China.
It's 80% cheaper than it's us competitors.
So companies here,
she'll try and to leverage the
hardware cost advantage in China.
So the third observation
is really important.
So in B two B space,
US startups are stronger.
We're in B two C and B two cheap
Chinese startups are stronger.
Yeah.
So we actually calculated the average
founding of the top three startup in each
industry.
Well Ai is applying to,
so the first part is the industry is
that US startups raise much more capital
then those in China.
And for the second part,
these are industries where
Chinese startups raise more money.
And if we dig into these two parts,
we find that these industries are more B,
two B industries where your
customers are typically enterprises.
Where the second part your customers
are more like consumers and also
government.
Okay,
so let's explain why is that in the u
s B2B ecosystem is well established.
That means AI startups can
get access to data easier.
You see all kinds of Saas model based
companies are very well developed in the u
s and also AI has a clear
values to enterprises because
AI can help enterprises
to lower the cost to
improve the efficiency.
That's why in the US a lot of enterprises,
I try AI technologist to help them.
What about China?
China is different.
In China,
US B2B ecosystem is not well established.
The trust,
that ecosystem,
the trust,
the system is not as well as developed
in the u s also because of the low cost
of human labors,
enterprises in China tend to hire more
people instead of trying to using AI to
lower the cost or improve the efficiency.
And also in China,
B2c has a higher gross and more data.
So startups doing B2C space
can access data much easier.
And in China you will see that the mobile
internet users are growing very fast.
Okay.
The last reason is BTG has a higher
revenue and the more data in China.
So in China,
Chinese government is highly
supportive of AI startups.
They give a lot of data to
start ups like since time.
So by working with government,
these big Ai Unicorns can access more
data and they can also get big contracts
from Chinese governments. So this were
drives the high gross of these companies.
I want to just talk a little bit
about B two c space in China. Well,
you can access much more data,
right?
If you look at this curve in China,
there's three times active mobile devices
than the u s and the number of food.
The delivery orders is much more like 10
times in the u s but this is in 2017 I
think today us has more food delivery,
right? You see like door dash,
Postmates or kind of delivering companies.
And also the mobile payments in China
is 50 times than the u s so you can get
access to these consumer
based data fairly easily.
And you know, AI is building
on data. So this is the key.
Okay,
let me give you some example.
One example in B2b industry is
a robotics process automation.
Well,
AI can automating large
amount of repetitive works,
right? Um, the typical example is Ui pass.
This company raised about 500 million.
Their revenue grow from a
million to a hundred million.
We seeing only 21 months.
You can see that the USS Enterprise are
paying a lot of money for these type of
company and it has over 2000
enterprise customers globally.
Okay?
So another B Two B space,
uh, is cybersecurity, right?
US enterprises paying a lot of money for
a cybersecurity companies to using AI
to help them to detect
and defend these attacks.
One company Stripe, uh, crowd strike,
they raised over around four,
500 million.
They actually analyze a trillion
events per week and it prevent,
uh, about 30 southern purchase
per year. Very significant.
Another example is agriculture.
Well,
the company plenty they can do over
like 300 times crop year old than
traditional farms and
only using 1% of water.
So you can see AI plays a significant
role here in terms of improving the
efficiency.
Okay,
that's,
rob has some example.
The B two c space where I'll try new
startups is stronger in entertainment is
one example.
You can use AI to do personalization.
Using Ai to do intelligent recommendation
by dance is a good example.
As I mentioned,
another industry,
uh, service robotics,
companies like UV tech, uh,
producing this, all kinds of, uh,
robotics to solve people to
interact with people. Well,
AI plays an important role of perceiving
the environment and interact with
people.
A good example of Btg is
the physical security space.
Well,
Chinese government is highly supportive
and give big contracts to startups.
Uh,
let's look at some number in China.
117 million security cameras are deployed
and you can expect 400 million more.
So there's way more number of security
cameras standing us since time is the
leader in the space.
But you also notice other competitors
from China facetime cloud walk R or raised
big amount of money. So the
B two g space in China, uh,
it actually attracts a lot of capital.
I also want to mention that B,
two B space in China is booming,
although you see that us
is stronger in B two B,
but now Chinese companies are paying
more attention to the space. Why is that?
Because the labor costs is increasing
because of the aging population.
Now, enterprises in China, I
pay more attention to cost.
Secondly, the far the high
growth of Internet mobile,
mobile Internet users are, the
close rate is diminishing. Now,
Chinese companies are looking at the
B to B two B space more because you
couldn't have such big roles
in B, two c anymore, right?
For most field. Oh, we're
going to say you some example.
For example,
a you'd be tech,
the our buting intelligent inspection
robots that can patrol and find safety
risks.
Since time it's also doing remote sensing.
They work on satellite data.
They attract the insights of the data.
Then can apply to
industries like agriculture.
Okay.
Now the takeaway for the u s is that
if you are doing something in B two B
space, it's huge opportunity
to expand that to China market.
Well example is database.
Visser is a US company backed by sequoia.
Uh,
they actually serving a lot of
customers in the u s but also in China.
You can see customers like Alibaba,
Jingdong and some other social apps,
social apps in China,
right? Say they started in the u s
but now they expand heavily in China.
Another takeaway is that if you are
working on B two C or B two g space,
actually you can learn a lot from China's
practice because Chinese startups have
tried really hard in these spaces
because B, two B is tougher, right?
They try to hard in B,
two C and B Two g and they have explored
various possibilities in these spaces.
That's real. Has some
example. Facial recognition.
You can see that facial recognition
technologies in China have been applied to
every industry. You can imagine,
right from uh, education,
finance, house, Kale,
entertainment, all tall security,
many industries right here.
You can imagine it's way,
way more ahead of us.
And that was an interesting example is
the license plate recognition, right?
You're going to sing you this as an easier
computer vision task to recognize the
license plate on your car.
Now in China,
many shopping malls have the systems,
this systems where recognize your license
plate when you get into the parking
structure and then we will get out.
It will automatically count how much
time you spent and you will pay for it.
Uh, no ticket needed, right?
And it improves the whole
traffic flow significantly. Um,
so these systems are
probably using China now,
but it's still early in the u s so for
startups in the US it's good to look at
some applications in China. Maybe some
of them you can apply to the u s two.
Um, another example is the
physical security space.
I mentioned this company, we invested,
they are doing security robots.
They actually learned a lot
from the PTG space in China.
These security robots will patrol
in office spaces during off hours.
Um, they would do human detection.
They will not do facial recognition,
um, because people will have
less concern about their privacy,
but they will detect humans and
see if there's some safety risks.
They will also collaborate with the
security guards in the u s so that if
there's some risk discovered,
the robot will collaborate with
Scott's to resolve these risks.
Okay.
Now the force observation we
have is that Chinese Unicorns,
I adopt some unique growth strategies.
One strategy is the horizontal expansion.
Right?
In China there are some Unicorns,
a pride,
a core AI technologies
to multiple industries.
Since time is one example.
They applying their computer vision
technology to over 10 industries and also
saves time sets up its corporate VC to
invest into other strategic partners.
They invest companies doing
entertainment company is doing Ai,
was healthcare company swinging
AI with smarter cities.
So since time is actually doing this
horizontal expansion to speed up its whole
grows,
right?
There's a number of other AI union
comes in China doing similar stuff.
Well we notice that for most Ai Unicorns
in the u s they are mainly focusing on
a vertical because they think it's
more capital efficient, right?
We think the horizontal expansion can
be applied to some USA I startups too,
but not all of them.
Yeah.
The second interesting strategy in China
is called multiple revenue streams.
Uh,
AI startups in the U in China,
they will provide freemium
models for early adopters.
Okay.
But how they make money,
right? If this is free,
they can get revenues from other streams.
That's real cat,
this license plate recognition
system as an example. So in China,
when's these companies? Butte,
these systems, it's hard to,
for them to sell to this shopping mall
owners. Right? Because shopping on there,
I don't want to pay much for that. They
say, oh, I don't need you to pay Etsy.
I would give it for you,
give it to you for free.
But in exchange,
let me put some ads in the entrance.
Now they sell the ads advertisements
to other companies to make money.
By doing so,
it covers their cost by later on where
more and more shopping was half their
systems. It's easier for them to
see all to many other shopping was.
So actually this is similar to
the [inaudible] gross strategy.
Well like Google provide free
services for consumers, right?
So that the adoption can be much faster.
So Chinese UNICORNS actually applying
this interesting growth strategy in B two
c space to be B because B
two B in China is so hard.
They need to sync clever ways to getting
into the B two c space to accelerate
adoption.
So they
try these kinds of growth strategies.
As I said,
B two C B two B is tougher. In China,
it's the customer adoption is slow.
So they need to expand to multiple
industries as soon as possible.
Secondly, there's squirrels,
pressure from investors in China.
So in China,
investors used to seek B2C grows,
which is more like explanation,
exponent, exponential growth.
We're in B two B space is harder.
So you needed to expand to multiple
industries to achieve faster grows and
suddenly there's high pressure from
the fierce competition in China, right?
So since time is actually competing with
these companies in a lot of industries,
right? These companies all
raised huge amount of money.
So the competition is really high.
So these companies will try to get
into different industries faster than
competitors.
Now the takeaway for us startups is
that for some startups you can try
horizontal expansion,
right?
If you have a core technology and this
technology can be applied to multiple
industries,
you may try this kind of growth strategy.
Some examples like self
driving technology,
we can apply to auto retail security.
If you do security robots,
supply chain management,
if you can do robots in warehouses,
right?
For robotic process automation
and also for fraud detection,
you can try a similar strategy because
it can be applied to many industries.
Secondly, the takeaway on
the multiple revenue streams,
I think a U S B Two B startups can
think of as a revenue stream than just a
customer.
Subscribe your services.
This actually can speed up
the customer adoption, right?
If you apply this strategy in the US,
maybe you can go much faster
than your competitors.
So lastly, I want to talk about
some opportunities for us startups.
So first, uh, you can get into
more markets as I mentioned,
the China and other emerging markets.
So secondly,
you as startups can learn from
China's practices, especially in B,
two C and PTG spaces.
Southerly,
it's interesting too looking at
industries with less competition.
So there are more opportunities for
people to start new AI startups.
Forsley a company is true,
the leverage,
some new tech trends in AI.
Um, so for the third opportunity, uh,
startups can step into
industries with less competition.
So we probably the numbers,
we find that for certain industries
there's high capital concentration,
meaning startups already
raised large rounds of capital.
So the competition can be high. But
for new startups, it's good to look,
look at some industries with less
competition. For example, education,
travel, energy, retail space,
tech, aquaculture materials,
and many others.
So in this space is no company actually
raised huge around huge round of
capital.
So it's easier for startups to getting to,
there's less competition.
So maybe it's good to pay
attention to these industries.
So the first opportunity is to look
at the new technology trends in Ai.
I briefly summarize into three categories.
Why is for data processing a Iot Ai
plus Iot edge computing five g these
technology or allow more
real time processing of large
number of large volume of
data? A second, the catch
query is computing power.
For example, tensor processing unit
GPU, right? It's powered by Google.
I think it's a good technology to leverage
to speed up the whole AI computation.
Quantum computing is on the way.
Um,
we may still need it to wait a few years
before it's gets more better developed,
but it's promising there.
So the category is a new
optimism's again is one example.
You can use it to generate
very real fake images.
For example,
some companies are using again to generate
faked training data for AI systems,
right?
You don't need to get a lot of data.
Now you can use the sis algorithm
to generate a more training data.
Some companies are thinking of applying
again to do some creation work.
Uh,
transfer learning.
When you apply your AI technology
from one industry to others,
you can transfer some knowledge you
already learned in wine industry, right?
If you also expand your system
from one country to others,
transfer learning can be also helpful.
Uh,
federated running, you
can do collaborative
collaborative machine learning,
right? Without centralize
the training data, right?
You can do more like distributed
computing when training a larger system.
Okay.
To summarize today,
I shared with you four key observations.
First,
R and D, USAA is ahead of China. Secondly,
for manufacturing,
China has some advantages
that u s company can leverage.
So that a, B, two C, B two
B us is ahead of China,
but in B two C and B to g,
uh,
Chinese car companies
are actually very strong.
So it's good for B two B
companies here to expand to China.
And also for B,
two C and B,
two g industries US startups
can learn from China's success.
The fourth episode,
Asian is Chinese UNICORNS.
I adopt unique growth strategies.
I think for most startups in Europe,
in the US,
maybe you could learn something from
China's growth strategies so that you can
get faster customer adoption.
Uh,
the opportunity is for the u s
companies first go into more markets.
Secondly, uh, you can learn
from China's practices. Thirdly,
getting into industries
with less competition.
I think there's a huge amount of
opportunities for AI startups to do right?
You can solve big problems in these
industries with less competition.
Lastly, pay attention to this new tech
trends and you can leverage some of the
technology to beauty your
Unicom right in the future.
Thank you everyone.
[inaudible].